hey everyone thank you so much for
joining us here for another what I hope
will be an exciting and educational
interesting version of Market takes I am
your host reporter Dion rabone with the
Wall Street Journal as you see right
there we're going high tech baby here in
uh 2022 but thank you so much for being
with us here on Market takes look we are
breaking down diving in opening up uh
doing all things to get into this fomc
meeting uh that we just had for November
Fed chair Jerome Powell we're going to
talk about what he said at the press
conference we're going to talk about
what the fomc said in their statement uh
we're going to talk about how the
markets reacted to all that we are going
to get into everything and anything that
there is to say about this big fed
meeting look first of all the first
thing I want to talk about is the rate
decision and the statement uh the
statement came out the markets really
liked it and then things got a little
different things changed a little bit uh
so we're going to talk about the outlook
for December's fomc meeting as well as
2023 because I think Fed chair Jerome
Powell really set that up with his
remarks at this meeting uh in terms of
what we can expect for the future at
least the market seemed to definitely
take it that way
um obviously we're going to talk about
the market reaction stocks bonds crypto
Commodities FX the dollar there were
some big moves and currencies that we're
going to talk about and of course we're
going to talk about what comes next so
thank you so much for being with us here
on Market takes uh you know I know you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me and I appreciate
that so look let's get into it right now
you know the FED raised rates by 75
basis points that's three times the the
normal average it's starting to become
you know a bit cliche or you know not
even necessarily correct because they've
been raising now this is the fourth 75
basis point hike in a row this is
incredibly abnormal and unusual policy
and I want to throw a chart up here on
the screen uh just to illustrate how
unusual this is now this chart goes all
the way back to 2009 you can see their
rates were really low right around zero
for years almost a decade
and then in 2016 you get that First Rate
hike and you see how rates gradually
went up there on your screen now you
look at 2022 when you got just like a
hockey stick that's what 75 basis points
over and over and over four times in a
row after hiking 50 basis points in May
after hiking 25 basis points in March
that's what this looks like so when
you're talking about the unusually fast
rate of rate hikes that we've seen this
year that's what it looks like compared
to a much more normal rate hiking cycle
that we saw from 2016 to 2019 and then
if you remember the FED famously
reversed course that was that pal pivot
1.0 in 2019 and then in 2020 you saw
that that move right to zero as the
coronavirus pandemic struck uh the U.S
so just wanted to throw that up there to
illustrate just how unusual this rate
hiking cycle has been so far in 22 2022
and why some folks are getting a little
bit worried that maybe the fed's doing
too much maybe they're moving too fast
and Wi-Fi Fed chair Jerome Powell really
responded to a lot of that in his press
conference today now the first thing I
want to do is like I said I want to talk
about that statement because this the 75
basis points was as expected the market
wouldn't have reacted too much but if
you were watching the stock market today
stocks were kind of down early on folks
were selling a little bit and then you
saw this statement come out and the
market shot up you saw stocks across the
board the Dow the s p the NASDAQ the
Russell all kind of jumping up and that
was in response to the statement I want
to read the first the big change in the
statement now there's a little bit of
fed speak it's you know some words that
normal people don't use a normal
conversation but I want to read it to
you and I'm going to break down what it
means uh the statement said this was an
addition this wasn't in the last or in
the previous months in September
statement this was added quote in
determining the pace of future increases
in the Target rate the committee will
take into account the cumulative
tightening of monetary policy the lags
with which monetary policy affects
economic activity and inflation and
economic and financial developments blah
blah blah fedspeak what that means
though is that the FED understands that
they've moved very fast you saw that
chart that was up on our screen just
that big hockey stick up uh in terms of
rates spiking up higher they're saying
hey we understand that we've moved very
quickly this is unusual and that
monetary policy Works to lag so what we
do in June might not really affect the
economy until December or until next
June we understand that and really what
the market was expecting that to mean
was okay we're going to slow down and
kind of start to set the stage for that
pal pivot 2.0 that Powell saying if you
look back at that hiking cycle from 2016
you go up up and then uh you kind of
hold and then down and that's what folks
were expecting to see really quickly
happen and fed share Jerome Powell
really kind of threw some cold water on
those expectations at his meeting the
Slowdown is the first step towards the
stop and then the next step is that
reversal where we get rates back down
from this level where they're at now
about four percent three point seven
five to four percent that is very high
relative to where we've been over the
past 12 13 14 years if you saw that
chart going back 2009 but big picture
when you go all the way back to the
1980s 1970s 1950s and Beyond this is
still low rates so a lot of folks were
expecting to see that Pals start to set
the stage for the Slowdown which set the
stage for the Stop in rate hikes which
sets the stage for the reversal we did
not get that
um now I want to take a step back and
talk about the outlook for December and
that really is you know what set the
stage for this meeting as we were coming
in right so we had that high September
CPI report CPI year over year was 8.2
percent and the core was up 6.6 now that
core reading which strips out food and
energy prices which are very volatile
which have been spiking higher most this
year and actually had kind of started to
come down the last few months strip
ripping that out core prices were rising
at a faster Pace than expected and the
highest than the fastest Pace since 1982
so you had that core inflation which is
what the FED really has more control
over rising at the highest Pace or the
fastest Pace since 1982. I also had
Eurozone inflation X Eurozone inflation
accelerating to 10.7 that's the record
high so remember central banks think
globally they act locally so what's
going on with the ECB what's going on
with the bank of Japan what's going on
with the People's Bank of China all that
factors into the fed's decision making
we also had a strong third quarter GDP
report 2.6 above expectations but we saw
the pce that's the fed's favored gauge
for inflation slow to 4.5 percent uh
overall and we also saw the GDP deflator
at 4.1 percent versus 9.2 or 9 excuse me
hitting the second quarter go back and
watch my live stream on GDP that we did
last last week check that out I explain
why that GDP report and that and why
that pce number were so important
basically it suggested that inflation
was slowing down and that we were
starting to see some of the things that
the FED wanted to see I talk all about
that in that video uh my last my last
live stream on Q3 GDP
um the big thing that folks are starting
to worry about is that the FED could
over tighten and fed share Jerome Powell
made a point to mention the salt the
strong jobs reports that we've seen as
well as the number of Labor openings
that we're still seeing the joltz report
job openings and labor turnover survey
which came out just last week that
showed there were still 10.7 million job
openings in the US the FED wants to see
that come down so there's not more job
openings or not two times as many job
openings as there are for every
unemployed person
um and and you start to see labor market
balance out they've made a big deal of
that we have also seen a slowing of the
jobs reports coming in so in July 528
000 jobs added in September 263 000 jobs
added uh in sept or sorry in August 315
000 jobs at it and then in September 263
000. so 500 000 300 260 000 that's
moving in the way the FED wants to see
things but again a lot of expectations
for fed chair Jerome Powell to start the
pivot he did not and we're starting to
see more folks worried that the risk is
that the FED over Titans does too much
sends the economy in the country into a
recession and that that hits a global
recession I want to read a quote here
from John or Gene Biven uh he is the
head of the BlackRock investment
Institute he says quote we see central
banks on a path to over tighten policy
we think the FED like other developed
Market central banks will only stop when
the severe damage from rate hikes is
clear is clearer sorry rates have
already hit levels that may trigger
recessions in our view that's the
growing consensus from economists a lot
of folks think the FED has already done
too much that rates are already too high
and that the economy isn't able to
handle it not just rates and abstention
oh my God rates are 2i no based on what
is going on with the economy with the
relative strength or weakness of the
economy a lot of economists are saying
rates are already too high we've already
hit these recessionary levels and the
likelihood of a recession is growing
significantly in 2023 and that was the
worry coming into this meeting so that
is how we sort of set up coming into the
Powell press conference and fed share
Jerome Powell uh who I mean if you were
looking for a hawkish pal if you were
looking for pal to come out here and
lower the hammer and say you know we're
still trying to Reign inflation well you
got what you wanted I I know a lot of
folks who are in the stock market were
not looking for that but that's what
they got
um you know Powell really came in here
and said a lot of things that I think a
lot of folks in the markets weren't
really expecting to hear
um he really talked about you know the
expectation for a slow down and rate
hikes going forward and he said quote we
still think there's a need for ongoing
rate increases but we still have some
ground to cover and cover it we will
again the Fed chair Powell saying yeah
you know the statement said okay we're
we see that we might be doing a lot of
damage to the economy we're going to
reassess and then Powell comes out and
says but we still have some ground to
cover and cover it we will
um he also said from a risk management
standpoint we want to make sure that we
don't make the mistake of either failing
to tighten enough or loosening policy
too soon seems like he still thinks the
worry is not doing enough rather than
the worry being that they have already
done too much and that they could be
doing very serious damage to the economy
he also said the change and when he's
talking about the change he talks about
the change from this aggressive policy
of rate hikes to changing to slowing
down to stopping to reversing course he
says that change could come as soon as
our next meeting or the meeting after
that that's important because markets
had already lined up a smaller rate
increase in December and then the fed's
slowing down and stopping further out
well he's saying it might come next
meeting it might come to meeting after
that which is in February might come
after that which would be down into
March of 2023. so it's really
interesting that Fed chair Jerome Powell
kind of took where the statement was
going which was positive for stocks
positive for risk assets and he really
went the other way and that's why we've
seen the moves in markets that we have
and so I want to direct your attention
here and just talk about what we saw in
the markets today because after that
statement was released you did see the
stock market really pick up jump higher
you saw treasury yields kind of come
down and then during the press
conference the Fed chair Powell put on
you saw just a complete reversal of that
right now as I look out at the stock
market the NASDAQ is down about 1.8
percent S P 500 down 1.2 percent the Dow
is down a half percent uh and really
again we were up positive after that
statement was released and markets just
did a complete reversal of that now the
other interesting picture as it always
is much more important to look out at
the bond market you saw yields coming
down as in folks buying bonds saying
okay it's safe to get back into the bond
markets we have seen liquidity really
dry up in the treasury market which
really means folks just aren't buying
Banks aren't getting in there and buying
big investment asset managers aren't
getting in there and buying folks are
kind of staying clear of the treasury
market and we're seeing liquidity dry up
and so you kind of started to see when
that statement came out people saying
okay fed's going to cool it they're
going to chill out we can kind of have
some certainty what we're doing let's
buy some bonds and then during this
press conference yields especially on
the long term really picked back up but
across the curve you saw the 10-year
note seven year two year five year one
year really across the curve yields just
picked and spiked back up and that's
also why you saw when you look out of
the currency Market the Dollar Rising
significantly against all other major
currencies you saw the Euro down Yen
down the Pound Down Swiss franc really
across the board all these currencies
falling in value against the dollar and
of course that hurt Commodities as well
you're saying crude oil still picking
back up because there still seems to be
a big pickup in crude that's you know
another story for another day but you're
seeing lower numbers on gold silver
you're seeing natural gas is up big
having a very big day today but uh
copper corn all these things kind of
coming down as expectations for what's
going to happen to the dollar is the
dollar strengthens those things are
measured in dollars and their values is
coming down as expectations for yields
to go higher as the expectation for the
FED to do more to raise rates higher
those are picking up which makes yields
go higher on bonds which makes the
dollar go higher which brings currencies
down which brings other currencies down
which brings Commodities down as well
looking out at crypto Bitcoin is still
kind of hanging on to some of those
gains from earlier in the day but
ethereum is down big almost a percent
Ripple is down about one percent uh we
are seeing a big downturn overall in
crypto Litecoin actually up about 10
percent but again on some of those
individual factors for those coins look
big picture right now the dollar is
strengthening again we are moving away
from this bullish Trend that we have
seen over the last month remember
October was a huge month for the Dow
having its best month in years or the
best October in years going up about 13
percent well looks like we could be
reversing that because that was largely
based on expectations for the FED to
start this pivot process to move away
from aggressive rate hikes and towards
slowing down then stopping then
reversing course and giving that pal
pivot or you know giving that that stock
market put that we have known the FED to
do it really seems like what we're
seeing now is the Fed you know fed share
power we're looking investors saying hey
you're moving too quick we are trying to
tighten Financial conditions make things
more difficult and really keep things
tight so that the real economy kind of
starts to slow down and those job
increases start to slow down one thing I
thought was very interesting about the
press conference from Fed chair Powell
is he talked a lot about individuals you
know we talked a lot about the jobs
Market he talked a lot about what
individuals have in their savings really
didn't spend much time at all talking
about corporations about how
corporations are flush with cash right
now so they can afford to have a couple
not so great quarters and still keep
prices High
he didn't talk about net profit margins
for corporations which are record highs
and are expected to move higher through
this year and those net profit margins
mean how much corporations are making
after they pay for higher prices so even
though the things they're buying are
getting more expensive they're raising
their prices at an even faster Pace
didn't talk anything about that or the
effect that these price raises are
having and as you know I talked about
this in a video that we did I want to
say it was back in June of this year why
corporations love inflation corporations
love inflation because it gives them
cover to raise prices and they raise
those prices by more than inflation and
that actually makes inflation keep going
higher Fed chair Jerome Powell didn't
talk about that at all I think that's a
very important thing we have to keep our
eye on last thing I want to mention
before we get out of here I know I'm
running long so I appreciate everyone
that stuck with me that's still here
with us on Market takes I want to talk
about how Fed chair Jerome Powell ended
his press conference uh today and it was
interesting because he was asked the
question about recession and about the
the odds for a soft Landing he said
quote the inflation picture has become
more and more challenging you talk about
how some of these supply chain issues
have resolved and you would have
expected Goods inflation to come down
now but that really hasn't uh what he
said was with regard to the inflation
picture becoming more and more
challenging that means we have to have
policy become more restrictive and that
narrows the path for a soft Landing
Powell really saying you know what we
might have to have a recession it might
be bad folks might be suffering hurting
we're okay with that because we've got
to get recession and control that looks
like the big picture here and that's
probably why you're seeing a lot of the
action that you are in markets look I am
Dion Robert Bowen reporter for the Wall
Street Journal this has been Market
takes like I said I know you could have
been anywhere in the world but you were
here with me and I appreciate that thank
you that's going to do it for us here on
Market takes we will see you next time
please come back and join us